[Music]  the moment we have been waiting all  bachelor season long for is here  here's how Knicks I'll season of The  Bachelor team two and a goodbye to sweet  Raven just don't know if I'm in love my  heart somewhere else and then a proposal  to Vanessa will you marry me  now that proposal was all love but  things got a little bit awkward very  quickly on the shows live after the  final rose special I'm not gonna  sugarcoat things  some days are tougher than others we  love each other but it's there have  there have been days that have been  difficult are you guys gonna get married  we're taking baby steps um you know I  think we're still in the process of  really getting to know each other so  what do you guys think are Nick and  Vanessa gonna be able to power through  everything they have coming up including  Nick's very busy run on Dancing with the  Stars let me know over on Twitter  [Music]  you